I have a concern about Chris of critical
theory critic this this whole this
everything that's happening right now I
believe is a Trojan horse I believe that
that James Lindsay and how he described
it as the Trojan horse is he's exactly
right on it's coming into our churches
do the division that it's causing right
now is insane because like you said it's
another gospel it's another religion
it's like because once again they
haven't their own epistemology so the
way that they discover truth is is from
a positional standpoint so so how do I
respond to that before you mention the
sort of lefty verse conservative
demographics that you're dealing with in
the church so as we've watched this
culture war just like explode all over
the place I know that all sorts of
churches temples at virtually every
organization secular or not is dealing
with some sort of like internal split
over how to deal with everything that's
happening these days literally from
coronavirus to black lives matter and
everything in between what what version
of that are you seeing these days
yeah there's definitely a political
part of everything I mean dude this is
insane like it's insane I keep on
telling my friends as I'm sure that all
your friends going what what is
happening in 2020
you know 4/3 there's a there's a there's
a conversation in the church right now
politically about the threshold of
threshold of religious liberty versus
you know government needing to you know
keep tabs and a lid on coronavirus and
so we're kind of I guess exploring that
threshold you know you got people who
that's that's it that's that absolutely
fine falls along ideological lines right
so there's there's seems like there's
two types of Americans there's ones that
want to they have a huge trust in the
government my wife is one of them my
wife is an Australian I'm a Canadian but
my wife is like she trusts the
government she's just like they are you
know they love us
and I want to meet she told me last
night she's like I want to be nannied
I'm like Mike a hot woman I was just
like okay have you luck with all of that
totally
so there you got my my wife Jasmine and
then you got me and I'm like the most
distrusting you know person of
government because yeah you know like
they who are these angels you know like
the old argument who are these angels
that are gonna make all these right
decisions for us so there's that that's
a huge conversation of the church and
that alone Dave was tearing us apart
all right like so you got like pastors
like calling up pastors and people
calling up people or like in the in the
faith community just being like you need
to trust the government authorities from
God and then
and then now you have of course you know
George Floyd's death which was horrific
and tragic and you have black lives
matter the organization that's kind of
occupied some space
in wake of the George Floyd killing and
then Ahmad Harbury because it looks it
looks
social media that young black men are
being hunted down and killed so so yeah
you have this major space and it's this
is another thing that's kind of dividing
us right now it's just like the
narrative to believe and and what we
ought to do about it and and regardless
of if you if you believe that narrative
or not you know Christians are called to
mourn with those who mourn and weep with
those who weep so finding that threshold
of going okay I might not agree with the
political narrative but I'm called to to
stand alongside you know people who are
in my life that regardless of whether I
don't know whether or not I believe that
they are their emotions are rooted in
any kind of reality and I'm arguing from
a you know if you're a conservative you
know like I have a responsibility
towards them to love them you know like
my wife is is terrified of airplanes
it's not rooted into anything logical at
all
but I'm the one that's stuck pulling the
bag and comforting her and getting her
xanax when we're on a fly that you know
so there's an element of that if you're
a conservative that you have a
responsibility towards the people that
you're in community with that you're
living life with and you know you know
quoting stats that my wife doesn't help
her flight anxiety you know like right
so finding how well you know is the mess
right walk yeah how worried are you
though that letting in this sort of
different what I would call a religious
belief system social justice that once
it enters the institution enters the
church that in many ways it will just it
will rot from the inside all of the good
things that you've been talking about I
mean this is what we've sort of seen
happen to every secular institution it's
happening to the New York Times it's
happening to the Washington Post it's
happening to Harvard and Princeton and
all of our liberal institutions so I'm
sort of fascinated where with this idea
that it could be entering you know sort
of conservative or religious
institutions and that they may not even
have the correct defense mechanisms to
purge it or keep it in favor that's
exactly what's happening
so it's not necessarily so for me I've
tried to dance this line we're like you
know the idea black lives matter it's
like it's an idea it's a saying I've
sort of divorced it from the
organization you don't like that but
I've divorced it from the organization
because you know yeah black lives do
matter and so if there are instances
where you know there's police brutality
that doesn't seem to fit you know the
resident I mean you know as we as we
examine the data that's one of the big
ones we know that you know the Harvard
Roland's his paper and we know like this
study that was done Heather McDonald
obviously lays this all out but one of
the things that I have a giant question
mark over is the police brutality part I
don't know if we're nailing that you
know well and so let's say that you're
like me where you're going okay that the
shooting part you know there's there's
no racial biases that's been detected by
three major studies but police brutality
do you have a question on that
like why are 30 percent of blacks being
you know accused of resisting arrest are
they resisting or is that what's
happening or the police you know being
antagonistic towards them or whatever so
so let's let's just say for example that
there is some antagonism that needs to
be dialed back
so I stand with my brother who feels
he's terrified okay and he's and he's
like Nate you know like I just feel like
block size does matter okay man black
lives matter okay I'm with you
black lives like I'll say that now the
organisation they believe in the
denuclearization of the family which is
doing nobody a service particularly the
black community in America right so so
so for me obviously I have some phat or
theological concerns to fry but I'm
walking this line where I'm in community
with with with with my black brothers
and sisters and so so for me like once
again
I have a concern about critical critical
theory critic this this whole visible
everything that's happening right now I
believe there's a Trojan horse I believe
that that James Lindsay and how he
described it as the Trojan horse is he's
exactly right on it's coming into our
churches do the division that it's
causing right now is insane because like
you said it's another gospel it's
another religion it's like because once
again they have their own epistemology
so the way that they discover truth is
is from a positional standpoint so so
how do I respond to that it's it's it's
it's almost an impossible dance but I
have to show rational compassion not
empathy because empathy is you know as
we've seen in the last like 10 15 years
in psychology is dangerous and your
biases come into empathy I have to have
what's called rational compassion so I
have to reasonably move through the data
move through the things that are
happening using my Christian worldview
and frame and framework in my
epistemology you know and and then as
I'm checking these these movements and
don't look at these are thundermans
right
everything has a demand we demand that
know that you overhaul us James says you
know you can't tear down the Masters
house that masters tools so we have to
completely change how we structure not
not just when the way we structure our
church organization but we also demand
that like the way that you go about
finding truth changes as well and so at
that point for me I'm not gonna fight
peripherals like in any good argument
you always argue first principles you
don't argue peripherals and so for me
when it comes to the black lives matter
movement when it comes to the things
that are happening on the streets and
the protests etc I'm not gonna there are
some things I think that are peripheral
and as conservatives we get a little bit
sidetracked by and so to me the critical
theory thing and this is why I think
James Lindsay
is just so on the money right now is
because it's the you don't go after the
fruit you go after the root and to meet
critical theory is the root of this
giant problem it's it's the reason why
the political narrative has been spun
the way it is and so to me that's that's
what I'm going after while holding the
hand of people that are hurting if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell